I think there's two things I've really
seen in my perspective the internet
changing one is who's using it and to
how it's being used you know I went to
school at UC Santa Cruz right when the
internet was really being developed and
I can remember doing my you know my
coding you know my das coding and I was
on computers land it was a very
impersonal medium and then websites came
where you went to the website and you
got information and maybe do the
ecommerce but what's really changed
about the internet now it's become much
more of an intimate of tool it's about
for many people it's about their life
it's about we go on Amazon it's about
the books that they might like you know
what's recommended they're reading the
reviews that they're their friends or
even strangers instead of just
advertisements so the whole internet has
become with Facebook with myspace is
become much more of an intimate and
personal thing and because of that I
think the the dynamics and who's using
it have really changed I think it
started off as sort of a white male sort
of geeky tool and now actually more
women are online the men are more women
are blogging the men are women it's
really a women's medium if you think
about it I mean we are through our brain
chemistry we're wired to be connected to
other people and the internet is such a
powerful way to connect whether through
you know myspace or Facebook or Twitter
you know I think a lot of these things
are going to come and go I think Twitter
will come and then you know who knows
there might be a new version of Twitter
the technology may change but the truth
is is that people are gaining
relationships in new ways than they ever
happened like I can talk to someone in
Ghana about a problem with genital
mutilation that I never was before so
it's become much more of an intimate
tool it's change politics
what's interesting I know within tell
Andy Grove is always poking holes in his
company to try to find out you know
where his competitors are going to come
in and take him out AOL at one time was
the you know breakthrough technology and
then all of a sudden aol's sort of an
old story in the news stories facebook
and sort of what will be next you know
after that there's there's so much the
convergence between the web and
television is completely is what's next
you know almost every household has a
television it's part of our lives it's
part of our identity and that intimacy
that we see both through internet and
also what people are enjoying watching
people love American Idol because it's
an intimate show they're seeing people
like themselves reflecting so I'm not
sure exactly where it's going but I know
we're going to continue to have
user-generated content I think people
are going to be booking their meal
creating their own television shows I
think that there's going to be much more
instant response to the way that
television works and we're just going to
see a convergence